it's time for a review the name is
dangerous that's the proof man but
suddenly they're transported into Narnia
in their own borders ship called the
Dawn Treader which is a very appropriate
name because it only seems to sail at
dawn yeah they're noticed that every
time it's on screen is always at dawn
what is the crew like let's sail to
adventure wait this guy has to be a
pretty purple haze
okay from the filming Prince Caspian
Queens now nothing we've had peace for
years well what's the but a green part
is eaten seven old guys do we have to go
find him wait so the karyotype kid is
really obnoxious and angry I'm obnoxious
and angry at my story Marcus taking way
too long
- chief comes along to make a crappy yo
Jeff you're a jerk into it so they come
across this invincible house where
magician lives and he's like you need to
connect second source in order to stop
the evil green farts why is it doing
father and daughter want to find their
mother who is taking the green part and
just be in it like you can stay on board
just keep in the back you don't
interfere with a black poking look our
mother cuz I'm a cute mouse and easily
marketable
so they need as much screen time with me
as possible
Oh maybe if you turn into a dragon okay
let me know the start to the grief Arts
hideout and it turns out the star is a
beautiful woman
no wonder astronauts keep going into
space if all the signs were not I joined
as a - it's one small step for man one
giant leap for my Johnson so there goes
in the lair of the green part and the
crew is like don't think of anything
whatever you think will suddenly become
real and then is like I can't help it it
just popped into here what just popped
in there no it can't be
what did you do Inman it's the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man
oh wait I mean a sea serpent you are all
gonna die but return he's like could you
put those seven swords on the table why
because they don't kill the monster why
don't you just kill them all so the
swords are laid down and the green part
is destroyed
hurry so they come across this great big
waver Aslan
and Aslan is like that is my kingdom you
may enter it but you may never come back
why so the kids are like we can't go we
have family waiting at home but the
mouse is like I sold enough plushies
I've met my character for lunch with
Circe at the Lucy Edmund are like we're
too old to come back to Narnia aren't we
and as LED is like my grandma go back to
your retirement home and get in your
wheelchair but we never see you again
of course bring your world I am known by
a different name Jesus
so the kids go back home and live
happily ever after but the cherry top
kid is like can I come back it all
depends on what on box-office records
oh okay sorry hon Arnie was a lot of fun
but for a movie series that stirred up
with The Lion the Witch in the wardrobe
you don't really see much of the line to
which are the Wardrobe and last line is
like I buy I know when she's like Oh any
green fur
oh and the Wardrobe is like baby
maybe I'm just nitpicking and let's
admit I'm very good at that Virginia's
oh there's an it now this is cherry bum
sing better I know some multicolored
farts that needs a peg wishing